recently I was in New York City and I
was walking down the street and a
Gentleman came out of his establishment
The Establishment is EJ's Luncheonette
and this guy Jay came out Jay Elmore I
believe and uh said hi we chatted he
offered up that he would make sandwiches
that are named after the three of us
could use a regular podcast listener I
thought that was very nice so uh we came
up with some ideas for sandwiches
I guess they're selling them at EJ's
Luncheonette
I'd like to know what's going on do you
know what do you have an update here
that's right I've been talking a little
bit with Jay who seems like a wonderful
person uh Sona you had a Euro uh you had
a corned beef kind of thing yeah and I
had a a matty melt on Hawaiian bread was
yeah what it was called yeah and then um
he gave me an update on this okay and
also he put the chilled Chum cocktail on
there remember that from uh this is a
good fan we have he really knows his
stuff uh he said just wanted to thank
you for everything I hope you all enjoy
having your own sandwich it was an honor
and a pleasure to do them should we add
the cocktail blah blah blah blah and
then just a fun fact for you the Matty
melt almost doubled the amount sold of
Conan and Sona sandwich on the first day
hmm things have leveled out since with
Conan sandwich and sona's Gyro thanks
again for everything truly super cool of
you guys to do you've made my day slash
week slash month slash year that's very
sweet uh nice wait a minute first of all
what he's saying is that initially your
sandwich took off and ours did not
I mean ours probably did fine but yours
went through the roof yeah yours again
what's in it it's Hawaiian bread and
then it's a Patty Mill essentially yeah
okay
uh and mine was I believe your classic
corned beef Russian dressing but I think
it's on a bulky roll possibly I don't
know
um I mean that's a great sandwich and
then yours mine was a Euro without
tomatoes what's a Euro again a euro is
uh it's in a it's a It's Greek and it's
a pita sandwich with uh with like donut
lamb donut and uh lettuce and Tzatziki
right and onions uh so your sandwich was
the initially the clear winner but I'm
what I find Curious is that then your
sandwich was fast out of the gate but
now it feels like it's
the Mania for it has died down no I
wouldn't say that I would say that
people wanted to give the other ones a
shot and then probably we're gonna see a
huge boost in the Maddie melt again as
they realized that was a mistake and
they're gonna go back to their true love
or they tried it and it sucked but why
would they try it so much well initially
it's not the same people buying it over
and over it's not it's not I'm out there
buying no first of all we all know that
you hired people Confederates agents to
go in there and purchase your sandwich
to uh to game the system
I think there's a lot of people who
aren't familiar with Hawaiian bread they
thought it was exotic they probably
thought it was a way to win a free trip
to Hawaii and so uh that that probably
skewed things a little bit then they
came to their senses and said man corned
beef Russian dressing That's a classic
oh there's no human that tastes Hawaiian
bread that will ever go back it's that
good hey Sona think of all the amazing
things in life that are expressions of
just you yeah I mean like the chocolate
that you had on your face when you came
in because you just ate that what was it
you were eating I was eating a giant
cookie giant cookie yeah and that's so
Sona okay or that song you stream over
and over again it's just so you what's
that song For You Twinkle Twinkle Little
Star yeah but it's for my boys and I
know still it's nice okay or you know
that podcast that comedy podcast you
just gotta listen to yeah Conan O'Brien
needs a friend exactly is that what you
listen to in your spare time yeah I love
it everything that makes you you makes
all the difference State Farm believes
Insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage selections could be
personalized by you and only you that's
cool I shouldn't shout but this is how
strongly I feel about it you go to
choose the plan you want by picking the
options that fit you like choosing to
bundle your home and auto policies is
what the State Farm personal price plan
is all about getting the coverage you
want at an affordable price just for you
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customers availability and
eligibility may vary what if I can find
someone who's had a taste of Hawaiian
bread and didn't like it they don't
exist isn't Hawaiian bread small yeah I
think you can get it bigger can you yeah
normally they come with those little
slider buns yeah yeah so it's like a
slider so maybe you were selling so many
because people yeah more thank you in
order to no look at the size appreciate
themselves yes they needed seven of your
sandwiches to equal one of mine and
that's why yours sold more per sandwich
there's a big one one piece let me see a
Hawaiian bread stop your
dickery also who wants a big Hawaiian I
do oh my God everybody do everyone
everyone wait a minute wait a minute
Sona of the three sandwiches only one
has an American flag sticking out of it
that's right we covered it and it's
gorley's that's why you're outselling it
because we're a patriotic people
Americans you cheated no because when
you idea to put that in remember the 48
Stars I know but I up
I'm admitting that I this Alters the
experiment because the fact that your
sandwich is flying an American flag and
you're
Giro
it's a Euro I mean okay you could
pronounce it gyro like yeah gyro there
you go it's also Hawaiian bread yeah
okay
um and it is according to beef what uh
it is a corned beef uh anyway my this is
what's happening your sandwich looks
like it's pro-american our sandwiches
are neutral but if you're buying
something at EJ's luncheonette you
assume
that our sandwiches are anti-American
because if well maybe they are if if one
person on the streets flying the
American flag yeah and the other two
houses on either side conspicuously are
not that means they're communist maybe
or yeah or they're anarchists or
anarchists or socialists but there's a
market for those people and our
sandwiches are for those people no don't
say that you hate America
no that's absolutely right no we've got
it right now you're a Nazi a Nazi no I
think that I I that's not is that even
Hawaiian bread yes I don't think it is
no it's regular that's regular bread
wearing a little Hawaiian shirt no
that's what it is here's what I think we
should do these are classic quips I'm
giving by the way amazing I want to
reach out Aaron we got to make this
happen we need to Gold belly these three
sandwiches to us which is a service
where you can fly food across the
country I think like it's in a little
cooler like you would put a heart and a
trans wow what a responsible carbon
footprint we're leaving Sir with like
three sandwiches named after ourselves
flown in a jumbo jet each with a first
class seat I'm mean I don't want to say
this but we could just buy this stuff
here and no no no no no no
like a true communist you guys
want to get a whole cooler scent here of
sandwiches
we're in Show Business and people in
Show Business have I want a leg of lamb
made up that was slaughtered on Staten
Island flown to me immediately that's
the way people behave it's just easier
for all of you guys to fly to New York
and try you know what no Eduardo has a
point yeah
Jay Jay can come here
yeah I want to update on what what the
South the sandwich selling rankings are
like what's the most current tally yeah
and who's winning and if you're in New
York and you don't buy this Euro you
hate Greek people
but you're an anarchist you're a
socialist who hates Greek people sure
and if you don't buy the patty melt you
you get kicked out of the country
frankly yeah okay so everyone's gonna
buy this that email
well listen
yeah
by the way honor working with both of
you
truly greatest talents I've ever been
associated with all right well there
you've heard it uh go to EJ's
luncheonette if you want to try our
sandwiches and I'm telling you corned
beef Russian dressing
um why are we buying these 10 why isn't
he sending them to us no we want it we
want people to go to EJ's and buy these
sandwiches he's talking about having a
service send them to us like Jay send us
these sandwiches
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right well anyway uh we'll get these
sandwiches somehow we'll figure it out
and we'll do it and I think a way that's
uh responsible yeah yeah irresponsible
that's important all right we'll update
you God bless and good night